just when it seemed that maybe that
judge Eileen Cannon appointed by Trump
might be his Saving Grace in the federal
classified documents case we have now
learned that special prosecutor Jack
Smith might be preparing to hit Trump
with 45 more charges in that classified
documents case including potentially
putting those charges forward in a
different venue like for example New
Jersey where Trump's Bedminster Resort
is located which also appears to be the
scene of some of these alleged crimes in
order to get around the possibility that
that trump-friendly judge Eileen Cannon
might be able to run interference from
Trump